après avoir passé près d'une décennie en
ch et celle des en raison de ces
dystrophies musculaires
jonathan marchand 45 ans savoure enfin
une première année en appartement
je pense que nintendo fait moi qui
tenteront
donc
en
quelques mois il est parvenu à se
trouver un emploi à s'acheter une
voiture et a re devenir financièrement
indépendants et le chèque emploi service
une allocation du gouvernement
provincial plusieurs permis d'embaucher
des assistants pour les fournir de
l'aide à domicile mais son combat n'est
pas fini selon lui ça prend une aide
plus organisés pour que d'autres
puissent suivre son parcours
[Musique]
à la veille des élections provinciales
il souhaite voir un changement de vision
à québec l'an dernier le gouvernement
legault avait promis un projet pilote
pour faciliter les démarches avant de
faire marche arrière
parce que ça demeure extrêmement
difficile de sortir de ch et s'est levé
comme il l'a fait surtout que les
procédures varie selon les régions ce
double daniel pilote 60 un résident dans
un ch et celle des en montérégie après
un homme démarche est lié encore aucun
plan pour le sortir de son centre
d'hébergement
et
après
[Musique]
à quelques jours du déclenchement de la
campagne électorale les partis se sont
tous engagés à mieux soutenir les
personnes handicapées
en attendant jonathan marchand poursuit
son combat et profite de son autonomie
retrouver
projet
ici flavie sauvageau radio canada québec